bro this don't say gay thing is
basically jesse smullet no for real like
they've made up a problem in their own
minds and now they're complaining about
a problem they made up and republicans
are complaining about how the problem
they made up is actually a good thing
and i'm like what is going on so like
i'm seeing ben shapiro tweeted them and
he's like why are you trying to
indoctrinate kids this bill stops that
i'm like no it doesn't
right it's like the left made it up
complained about it and then the right
argued it was a good thing but none of
it is true
they they got baited into you know
defending it essentially yep yeah that
was one of those it's the don't say
straight bill by the way that was the
one as as soon as i saw i was kind of
like whatever you guys are saying it's
not that i go what's that what's
actually going on here everyone seems to
be lying yeah yeah it's it's it's so we
called it i've called it the
anti-grooming bill as kind of a point
and i say that to to as a point to
counter the democrats calling it don't
say gay no i know but it is that is the
sorry i was gonna say the better point
is don't say straight
there's literally no difference between
straight and gay when the context is
identity or orientation so if the bill
restricts classroom discussions from
preschool to third grade on orientation
then you can't say straight what about
don't secretly talk about sex with
students bill can we
it doesn't stop that
it actually that's the thing it actually
encourages this is the craziest thing
the bill encourages teachers to secretly
talk to children about these things i
thought that there was banning them from
not really talking to children no you
aren't correct yeah this sucked to have
kids what you're saying it's like the
catholic church being like any sex talks
got to be one-on-one the bill restricts
classroom discussions from preschool to
third grade on gender identity or
orientation that's not the bulk of the
bill like the actual bulk of the bill is
parents must be informed about medical
issues involving their children that's
it so it's like a kid who stubs his toe
tell the parents a kid got hurt if you
okay let's say that you are
uh the person who would be
on the non-republican side super in
favor of
kids is there anyone arguing that sex
needs to be taught to jk yes yes like is
that 100
likes
so how old are you when you're
jk like six five so they're saying
five-year-olds need to be like here's
what they know for no no it's it's
four-year-olds yeah pre-school is four
years old and third grade goes up to
eight years and where's that where are
they arguing that should happen so the
issue is that this was like anyone
legitimately like is there so
you know not like fringe bloggers or is
this cnn runs the story
about
kate mckinnon i think her name is on snl
oh yeah and she does a bit where she's
first pretending that it's like you
can't insult someone by calling them gay
and then she realizes what it actually
is but cnn
shows
the bill would restrict discussions of
gender identity and orientation in
preschool through third grade over kate
mckinnon talking about it so i'm like do
we sit here
and just assume
that the people who go on cnn the people
who watch cnn aren't aware of what the
bill is and genuinely think it's
stopping kids from talking about
orientation or do we assume based on cnn
accurately reporting it they know and
they're trying to teach four-year-olds
about
sexual activities yeah yeah because it's
your i see what yours point is you go i
mean
if you're lying at least you're just up
to your old tricks but if you're not
lying worse yeah or whatever so my thing
is uh it's also just strange where you
go i get the i think that people just
they leave any sort of thought when they
go this is what our team thinks isn't
you go really you wanna like what grown
adult really wants to take someone
else's kid and be like let me tell you
about sex when they're four
but i think but i don't know
my friends my friends the bill doesn't
stop this
a teacher a janitor a school district
employee can welcome janet yeah the
janitor should be teaching you that i
mean i learned all about stuff
because the bill says school district
employee
they can walk up to a group of 10 kids
and say kids i'd like to talk to you
about why you're trans and the bill
doesn't stop that what the bill stops is
that if they're in the classroom for a
specific classroom discussion well does
it encourage that though it just it
doesn't have anything to do with that
you're saying they're allowed to have
one-on-ones but they can't be teaching
in a group setting they are on group
settings they're not allowed in
classrooms they're not allowed in
classrooms specifically means the bell
rings it's 9am the teacher walks in and
says everybody turn to page 17 and we're
going to learn about oral right they
can't do that they can after class walk
into the woods and show them the what
about all that but they can they so
let's say there's a group of kids and
they're talking about the stuff the
teacher can hear it and walk over and
say ask me anything you want and we'll
talk all about it they don't got to tell
the parents all of that is still
acceptable and fine as far as
republicans are concerned i don't know
because they're still in a classroom
setting even if it's after classroom
discussions
even if it's like after school if it's
in the comments it's essentially about
the curriculum that's what the
argument's about right right so
one-on-one is is in the clear there may
be some questions about with more than
one person but nothing is stopping a
teacher from having a let's let's just
let's just go to that point a teacher
can walk up to a student who's four
years old by themselves pull them out of
the classroom yeah you said uh right
yeah and
but there's there's one thing the bill
does they can't say don't tell your
parents they can't do that so they can
still have private discussions about
this stuff they can say literally
nothing but if they say don't tell your
parents now they're crossing the line
they're the teacher says don't tell your
parents yeah and then what's this
it should be how they say don't tell
your parents it could be like hey they
can't they can't better not tell your
parents well they can't discourage or
dissuade uh students from talking to
their parents about medical issues
so this is the crazy thing about the
bill and we talked about it for like
three days now is that if a kid
trips uh slips on vomit and breaks his
arm the teacher might go up to him and
be like we're gonna get sued because
that's our fault and they go to the kid
and they say don't tell your parents how
that happened just say you you you were
playing outside yeah don't tell them
that i had a couple extra today in class
no for real and barfed because
so i mean obviously drinking in school
will be illegal for the teacher but
let's say a kid trips on something it's
a school's fault and the school just
comes up to them and knows the kid's not
smart enough to address the issue and
says don't tell your parents the kid
goes home with a broken arm they call
the parents out he was playing outside
the kid doesn't tell his parents because
the teachers told him not to no no now
the insurance now this insurance like
we're not covering it and the school's
like it's not our fault and now that
this poor middle-class family is being
put out so that the reason i bring that
up is that the democrats narrative on
the whole thing is just like they
literally made it up it has it has
nothing to do with this bill it is just
like that that's why i'm calling the
bills
don't say straight in your mind you kind
of go yeah
who even came who even ever read this
and interpreted that was what was
happening yeah gay and straight's not a
medical thing so what is the truth
mental health what is the trans uh
component nothing identity and
orientation i suppose well wasn't it
that if you're
you know uh k through two and you are
taking hormones you're supposed to
notify the parents is that the idea not
in the bill uh the bill just says if the
the teachers can't give medication to
students
yeah if a student would be prescribing
any kind of medication the parents must
be informed
i i'll tell you this i'm trying to get
to the bottom of this to be honest
because it did feel like i go what the
hell is actually happening here so let's
say you're a kid that's cool propaganda
salad coming around let's say your kids
at school and he gets a stomachache and
so they say we want to give the kid kids
some pepto make his stomach feel better
gotta tell the parents
democrats are opposed to that that's no
because the the reality here is they're
saying don't say gay as a psychological
attack conservatives have fallen for it
conservatives are playing into that
narrative because the reality of the
bill is they want to make sure parents
don't know what's happening to their
children period it's not about gay it's
not about straight it's not even about
any one specific thing it's about saying
don't let parents know what we're doing
in general because then we can now take
that principle and do some critical race
theory do teach them whatever we want so
they claim they're not teaching critical
races more about than that
it's it's just
you know it wasn't until covid we
actually learned what they were doing to
kids because the zoom classrooms and the
teachers got freaked out and like we saw
these leaked calls where they're like
parents are finding out what i'm telling
their kids
that's what it's about the the teachers
can't teach children things you know
outside of curriculum t parents can sue
the teachers if they go outside
curriculum
teachers can't you know uh take medical
action against a child without parental
consent or or advisement if a kid has a
medical mental or physical issue they
have to inform the parents and then one
provision is
preschool through third grade you can't
have discussion classroom discussions on
uh orientation or identity it's there is
also very reasonable things it's not
unwritten you know what else there is
something to be said about if you want
to
teach like essentially your world view
and propaganda then be a university
teacher because that's like that's
basically the job you get to do your
course and you can kind of teach
whatever you want and which is very
world view and vary what you think if
you want to teach grade seven you know
maybe just teach the stuff you guys have
never ever played lemmings
yeah uh yeah
back in i played on like a windows 95
yeah i don't know he came up with the
idea
npc i think it was sheamus yeah the idea
would be
i think i was talking about how i play
the game lemmings on my phone and the
idea is someone mentioned they're
programming a version of it where
instead of lemmings they're npcs like
little npc meme and we're gonna you know
when you when you wanna like dig through
a wall he puts on like an antifa mask
and starts like vandalizing the wall i
thought this russia stuff in general was
a very
you know from back to back with covid
just to show the extent to which it's so
easy
to get people hyped up on for whatever
you want them to be hyped up about and
it's like it's funny it's funny to point
out sometimes but you go it almost would
just be like man it's almost just better
to be a politician because you go it is
or whatever if you have a real agenda
it's very easy to get people jazzed up
for whatever you want them jazzed up
about yeah yeah yeah uh and nothing and
the hypocrisy doesn't matter i mean you
know we're talking about all this train
stuff but like all the stuff that they
were mad at people about for four years
straight
ukraine could be doing at all of that
and it could be you know on video and we
all we don't care i mean there was that
you guys before the show you pulled up
zelinski and he was doing like roman
salutes nazi salutes and he was making
jokes about buying hitler's book and all
that stuff well he's making jokes about
how the mineconf was sold out in the
ukraine which is because the azov and
western ukraine are like militant nazis
they've been around no but imagine that
was you know some you know politician
running for new york that's all you know
yeah but also like
you know putin was like we're gonna
denot suffer and everybody's like okay
whatever like that's your pretext nobody
actually believes that and then you were
the ones
yeah well but everybody but then you see
it you're like oh there actually are
like quite a bit
yeah like the all nazis and then
remembering the ottawa thing the
protesters and they go oh they're look
there's like a confederate flag there's
like a nazi flag you're all nazis and
then you go okay so this is
a guy then are all these people in
ukraine nazis then yes all the people
you also they
in western ukraine during world war ii
they were like insurgent nazis that were
fighting on the side of the germans
right yeah but left over from when when
ukraine was a german protectorate after
world war one so there's definitely like
nuance to all of these points but the
point my point is that the nuance is
granted
very differently in every situation it's
like and it's almost it's pretty
egregious to the point where it's
interesting i would even see with other
people like oh you can't they're not
going to get hyped up about something
completely opposite a day later are they
and they will thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there